[Music]
welcome to the reason Round Table your
weekly dose of libertarian insight into
the decidedly non-libertarian world we
all live in I am Matt Welch joined by
Nick Gillespie Peter suterman and
Catherine mengu Ward happy Hanukkah
everyone howdy
happy Monday hey Matt so
uh President Joseph uh Robin at high on
the second on Friday signed a stop-gup
stop gup wow the hell
us a Steffi Graf Government funding bill
designed to give Congressional
negotiators until this Friday
December 23rd to wrap up work on a
reported 1.7 trillion dollar chromabus
package that would keep the federal
bureaucracy in business until we do the
same exact stupid exercise next year
lawmakers report that they are just
hammering out the final details of the
so-called must pass Mega Bill saying in
statement last week that they had quote
reached a bipartisan bicameral framework
that should allow us to finish an
Omnibus appropriation spill that can
pass the House and Senate and be signed
into law by the capital P president in
completely related news the treasury
Department last week announced that the
federal government just for the month of
November ran a record-shattering 249
billion dollar deficit
spending a half a trillion dollars while
taking in just one quarter for context
that 249 billion dollar one month
deficit number is more than the amount
that the governments of all but 20 other
countries in the world spend every year
one of the main drivers of debt is
borrowing costs which are up a
staggering 53 billion dollars over
November 2021 turns out when the
government borrows and redistributes
vast amounts of money this can lead to
inflation which can lead to higher
interest rates which makes borrowing
more expensive just at the moment when
your debts have ballooned because you've
just borrowed and redistributed vast
amounts of money
this economic Insight brought to you by
any third grader who can count Catherine
I was at a menorah lighting event last
night in New York City uh at which
congressman Richie Torres a Democrat uh
said normally Congress doesn't really do
much but this week I actually have to go
back and vote on the annual spending
Bill what's wrong with this picture
this could consider doing
dual year
bold Provo
improved governance and improve my
[ __ ] mood it's I don't know I'm so
mad right now about like I'm not sure
why I'm taking it personally and I will
be examining that later but like this is
absurd it's absurd they knew all year
they needed to do a spending bill they
know it's it's not like a big surprise
that creeps up on them and yet every
year they behave like college students
who have not yet learned this lesson the
hard way and
um
I I don't I don't know I I appreciate
that I have uh colleagues who are
similarly outraged especially Jacob
sullum like I wish I felt as strongly
about almost anything as Jacob Solomon
feels about how badly Chuck Schumer has
screwed up marijuana banking which will
now be shoveled into this bill just as
one example
uh Peter 10 years ago you were one of a
A Chorus back then uh of voices singing
about the Congressional
what's wrong my guy wow wow
can we get him into a stroke center
immediately a channel budget offices
long-term fiscal Outlook uh which back
then uh was a busy freaking out people
using words like unsustainable and
really super duper unsustainable uh uh
now that
um the future that it was always warning
about is the presence
is there anyone besides you who talked
about this anymore there's Eric babe and
the committee for a responsible federal
budget sure that's a that's the happy
hour I want to be invited to yeah so I
mean reading the coverage of this it's
amazing when I started reading news this
morning at 7 30 in the morning all the
reports were still like well we don't
know what's in it
like they had a framework but they
didn't have any details or any
information on what was really going to
be in this bill and then by like 9 30 or
10 there was a bunch of stuff and it's
just it's just amazing the sheer kind of
bunkers number of different things in
this bill
so like
Boeing jet safety protocols
maybe some big deal corporate tax
changes uh with regards to expensing
research and development costs maybe an
extension of the child tax credit that
was included in that giant spending bill
that the Democrats and Joe Biden did
right when Joe Biden came into office
and then expired last year and maybe
they're gonna maybe they're gonna
unexpire it
even though it was supposed to be
temporary although at the time
admittedly there were a bunch of
Democrats saying we're passing this on a
temporary basis with the intention of
making it permanent but then it then it
wasn't so who the hell knows uh State
conservation funding so like for all the
endangered species that's an in this
maybe again we don't know for certain
um also election reform like all the the
election reform stuff that uh that is
supposed to prevent you know the
confusion and some of the lack of
clarity about what happened uh on
January 6th of uh you know uh
like that's that's maybe gonna be in
this and and it's just like you know
everybody knows that old saying
government is just the word for things
we choose to do together I think we need
to update it
to like government is just the word for
a single multi-trillion dollar spending
and everything else bill that gets
written and passed without anybody
reading it in the space of a single week
at the end of every year
or it's the things we choose to do to
each other because we hate each other uh
speaking of hey let's go to Nick
um uh this is a bill filled with love uh
we're there's not a lot of hate I want
to extend a Peter's conversation but
before that Nick since you've written uh
a number of great pieces over the
history of Reason magazine uh and uh and
everything else about
um the size Before the Flood government
spending yeah and whatnot uh this looks
like right now we're on track for a a
deficit of this fiscal year of 1.9
trillion dollars which would be uh more
than what the 1.4 trillion of last year
uh the largest non-pandemic deficit in
history the the chromabus is expected to
add between
240 billion to 585 billion on top of
that and maybe you know a range that
just tells you how how clear we are
about what's in this thing right it's
like maybe it's going to add a whole lot
to the deficit plus or minus maybe it's
going to add a whole lot more than a
whole lot to the deficit and let's not
sleep on the five trillion dollars sort
of give or take over the next 10 years
um so uh Nick was Joe Biden telling the
truth a Zeus campaigning before the
midterms or was he telling the whole
truth
um that when he was bragging on how he's
reduced the deficit uh you know I mean
this is you know it's always time for a
Seinfeld quote but you know this one is
better than most which is as George
stands of once canceled Jerry it's not a
lie if you believe it and that is that
sums up the entire budgeting process
there's a republican version of this
which we won't be seeing for you know
some time because they're idiots
um but the Democratic version is now we
are reducing the deficit and then
they'll come up with some explanation
for why despite increasing deficit
numbers it is in fact declining
um for me the big takeaway
um and as somebody who's been writing
about budget stuff for you know like 20
plus years at this point is that we're
not even talking about what's this this
bill or discretionary spending stuff
that Congress votes on every year takes
up 30 percent of federal spending so
there is 70 of what the government is
actually spending uh most of that is
so-called mandatory spending some of
some of it is interest on the debt which
of course is much higher now because as
all of us inflation Hawks were you know
carping about forever
um you know that's and so I can
completely mix metaphors those chickens
are coming home to roost uh you know
from the Hawks who Carp at things but
you know there's that is possibly the
single biggest thing that worries me the
most about this is that as we talk about
this and we need to and we need to drill
down on all of the idiot spending that
is involved in all of this we are not
even talking about the where the money
is
um so the those mandatory spending items
particularly the old age entitlements
we've had to spend more over time it's
not like it's flat uh that continues to
increase as does the uh The Debt Service
and the it's a great creation to you
know have split and this goes back
decades but to split the budget into to
you know so-called mandatory and
so-called discretionary spending
because it really does let the
government Congress uh you know and the
president to some degree off the hook
you know they're like well you know we
would obviously tackle that if we could
but it's mandatory so we really can't we
just have to let it go
um and grow and double I mean it's like
an infinite you know sourdough uh
starter that is just going to take over
the whole well I'm calling back to the
early metaphor layering here the
internet
the internet was clogged instead of Elon
Musk tweets it was sourdough stuff
coming on right I'm glad that is over
but
uh the um thing that was amazing too is
when I really started writing about
budget issues around 2000 2001
um you know the the shorthand was the
federal budget is comprised by two two
parts mandatory and discretionary
spending Each of which take up about
half of spending and that was back down
through anymore
um the last project under Bill Clinton
was 1.8 trillion dollars so nominally
less than the deficit will be this year
so it is true that that the the deficit
has come down from its pandemic High and
the Biden Administration is using that
fact to argue that under that President
Biden is somehow or another responsible
for that but the reason the deficit has
come down from its pandemic high is
because we are no longer passing
trillion or two trillion dollar pandemic
relief bills every couple of months like
we were starting in uh April or so of
2020. uh and also those bills were
packed with temporary spending that was
intended to to end at some point and so
Biden wasn't responsible for about four
trillion of the six trillions that was
spent right well the first part of the
first couple of bills were passed under
President Trump
so Biden is arguing that because that
that spending has expired as planned as
passed under somebody else his
administration should get credit for the
falling deficit when you actually look
at the policies that President Biden
himself has signed into law they will
add trillions of dollars to the deficit
and are responsible for for uh the
deficit was was already going to grow
they are responsible for increasing the
amount that the deficit is expected to
grow over the next decade and so it is
on the one hand true that thanks to the
expiration of a bunch of pandemic
spending the deficit has fallen from its
peak
but it is also not true that Joe Biden
deserves any credit at all for reducing
the deficit and in fact if you are
somebody who cares about the deficit you
should be opposed to the policies that
Joe Biden has signed into law
you know if we can flip that too it's uh
you know and again because it you know
the Republicans had such a terrible uh
you know turnout or you know outcome in
the election
um that we it's going to be hard to
think about them as a dominant party you
know although that can you know they
control the house so they they took that
they might win the the presidency in
2024 to follow through on what Peter is
saying is that this spending increases
went up under Donald Trump even before
covid and from a Libertarian perspective
this is not to say okay the two parties
are exactly the same they are rotten in
their own individual ways but one thing
that they share consistently is voting
for more and more government spending
both permanent and temporary or you know
mandatory and discretionary when they
are in power and there's got to come a
point where this you know it has to stop
we're seeing the things that you know
large-scale non-stop government spending
debt Finance government spending does
and it slows down long-term economic
growth it increases deficit spending and
it destroys uh long-term uh you know
ability to kind of change the way the
trajectory of where the government is
going and what kinds of policies we're
actually doing it's uh you know it's
deeply deeply disturbing it's
inflationary and um you know we need to
have a bipartisan consensus at least or
an acknowledgment that they're going to
do something about it or we're never
going to speak of this again and we
should all move to underline what uh
what Nick just mentioned because people
react to this with surprise I find
um is that pre-pandemic federal spending
under Donald Trump in three and a half
years increased more from the beginning
of his term to that three and a half
year mark then federal spending
increased in Barack Obama's uh eight
years as president which is people don't
want to believe it and also it's true
Catherine you referenced the Chuck
Schumer marijuana Banking Act
um give you the choice either to expound
on that or any other thing that is
tucked in or is expected to be tucked in
to this must pass never going to be read
uh bill that's going to be up by Friday
yeah I mean I um you know I think Peter
and Nick both eloquently
uh attempted to drive home how
incredibly large these numbers are but
in some ways I think it's more troubling
when what goes into these bills are
things that are have really are not
spending at all like it's one thing to
be like okay we got to do a budget
because budgets are a thing but
um the rush to dump things that should
be
clearly should be and sometimes have
been separate pieces of legislation that
are substantive that are not primarily
about spending at all is the stuff that
troubles me more so the marijuana
banking thing is an example of that
the short version is that Chuck Schumer
uh vote what was the old line that John
Kerry was it John Kerry the like I voted
for it before I voted against it do you
remember that from back in the day
um he voted against it before he voted
for it so there's he had a Schumer had a
different version of marijuana banking
that he wanted uh he murdered in its
cradle this bipartisan should have
passed
um build the safe Banking Act and now he
wants to shove it into this last minute
um gigantic bill in order to get it
through because his thing didn't work
out but the other thing I want to talk
about is is the thing that suiterman
mentioned the um the Electoral count act
which is going to be shoved in there
this is arguably the most important
thing to get right this year
legislatively like if if the
presidential election doesn't go well
next time because this
set of rules wasn't carefully considered
and crafted in an ideal manner
the consequences are going to be
disaster because they did it at 1am on
Thursday and I'm pretty sure that this
is not carefully crafted in an ideal
manner because they're going to do it at
1am on Thursday right before the year
ends now to be fair this is language
that was already debated right I mean
this is you know it passed the house
it's it moseyed its way through the
normal process but
the whole problem right is the last
little fidgety details
um and you know what happened last time
around was that it was not clear who had
final Authority in some ways to certify
these votes to to certify these
legislators and we we cannot let these
electors we cannot do that again and the
fact that we are willing to just Chuck
this into this big dumb messy spending
Bill and hope for the best to me is like
the greatest evidence yet the Congress
is not being in any way serious about
its obligations to the American people
uh Nick are there any other elements of
the bill that are attracting your uh
specific eagle-eyed attention
um mostly what I I was looking at in the
uh the budget bill was the misdirection
so I would say no I my eye is firmly on
that big fat 70 percent uh and the
actual the interest on the debt is
really worrying because again as
somebody who's been you know shouting
about uh inflation caused by government
spending and persistent deaths in lower
uh long-term growth and the worry over
uh heightened interest costs this is
this is where we're at I want to give a
special shout out to uh Jonathan Chase
to Steve Bennett at MSNBC to a bunch of
other people who uh Joe Biden
the second um and a bunch of other
people who in the month of October were
busy saying that the most underreported
uh political story uh in in the run-up
to the midterms was that the Republicans
were about to shut down government
because they were going to cut Social
Security and Medicare and they're going
to hold uh they're going to hold
government hostage and actually engineer
a global economic breakdown I'm not
exaggerating none of this is hyperbole
the writing to this extent in the past
uh because
um some of us said you know what we
would have noticed
probably the Libertarians might have
noticed that this was happening uh
here's a quote from Richard Shelby the
um lame duck or outgoing uh a republican
uh from Alabama I believe uh and uh he's
a lead negotiator on the Chrome nibus as
it speaks uh here we go uh so I think
it's irrational to shut down the
government always it's the wrong message
the American people don't want that a
few people say well we will go to the
edge of the Earth we'll make people do
so and so I think it's best to try to
work it out you have to give and take a
lot of things are in the bill or will be
that I don't like and I wouldn't vote
for but military veterans safety nets
for people and everything let's do it
so you're wrong people it'd be all right
to go ahead and admit that I will not uh
set my watch uh for that uh but that's
an excuse to Pivot to what Shelby just
mentioned which is military veterans and
such because
um it's not just the chromabus that gets
passed in Washington's annual let's do
our jobs week
um it is also last week there was a by
overwhelming uh bipartisan majorities
was passed uh an
858 billion dollar National Defense
authorization act uh that is uh 45 uh
billion dollars more than Biden asked
for it's a one-year increase of 10
percent over a baseline that wasn't
exactly small
um we spend more on defense than the
next 10 uh Big Spenders government
defense people combined you can
hyphenate all that it works uh it is
also more the Pentagon gets more than
the 10 uh uh seconds or the 10 other
largest cabinet agencies combined so
Catherine
um from your point of view as a uh as a
person uh What uh are the problems the
potential problems uh with the us
spending 100 million dollars on the
military per hour
so many potential problems one of which
we've seen in action this year right um
which is that
when you have an enormous pile of
weapons that you bought with the
versions of this spending in previous
years
people ask you for them
and sometimes you you give them to them
so this is obviously what has happened
in Ukraine and I think an interesting
thing about the kind of rhetoric around
the the Pentagon spending this year is
there are separate Appropriations for
Ukraine right like the Ukraine stuff is
happening you know in a different bucket
but the reason that we need so much more
money for the military this year
according to Advocates of this
absolutely enormous bill
is that we got to rebuild all of our
stockpiles because we gave all the cool
weapons to Ukraine
um and this is kind of like a
self-perpetuating cycle I always think
about
um you know there was sort of a neocon
moment uh that I was privy to in My
Weekly Standard days where some of the
arguments genuinely did amount to like
if we you know what's the point of even
having the world's most powerful and
expensive military if we're not going to
just use it sometimes yeah if your
stereo goes that loud why wouldn't you
blow out your ears correct that is a
very good metaphor I'm surprised to say
for your stereo metaphors could you have
smashed that a little up Peter though
please I don't know what that means but
um the you know this idea that
we have to replenish the stockpile and
of course the reason that we were called
upon to use the stockpile in first place
is because we had the stockpile and why
do we have the stockpile because we
wanted to be ready in case we needed to
use the stockpile for stuff like this to
some people this is a working system to
some people this is like yeah we did it
this is the whole idea I am not sure
this is the right way to do it I beg to
differ uh Nick back in 2015 you
criticized uh Rand Paul who was then a
serious presidential candidate it's hard
to remember uh you criticize him for
proposing a significant increase uh in
the Pentagon budget all the way up to
nearly 700 billion dollars
that's like seven years ago we're at 858
million now uh were those tea party era
politics well it's a it's a rebuilding
Year Matt that's true you know we had a
we had a bad couple of Seasons we got a
new owner and uh you know we just got to
put more money into the stadium and to
the Personnel it's that like is it was
that just a hallucination the stuff that
was happening 10 years ago I mean
we were we the the word sequestration
was found like on a daily basis in the
newspaper there uh we never came back
from ever uh I guess it's when the
government shut down and like whole
parts of the country haven't been heard
from since what what was that and uh our
uh like people even gonna be looking
back at that as like this a Fantastical
micro moment that must have been a
glitch and then it went away immediately
well you know I mean you uh earlier
referenced the last Bill Clinton budget
and that is unfathomable that you know
that the government spent so little
money on so much stuff and now we just
spend so much stuff with nothing really
to show for it um you know that to me
and in a lot of ways there are many ways
to parse the kind of uh you know rolling
tragedy that is uh government massive
unpaid for increases in government
spending but one of them is like what do
we have to show for it and I remember
when George W bush left office that was
one of the things you know he gave the
he oversaw the biggest dc-based you know
party
um since Lyndon Johnson there really if
if we're going to monkey with the
Constitution please make it that nobody
from Texas can ever be president again
but you know like there was nothing to
show for it like it's not like there
were 60 Maseratis parked on the lawn or
anything like that and I think with the
defense spending you know we have
something like that we have a couple of
graveyards you know new freshly minted
graveyards around the world and we're
looking for new ones to to kind of uh
dig up and things like that but we don't
really have anything to show for it
um and it's I I don't I don't even know
how to deal with this on on some
profound level
um and this is also in a moment when
um you know America is actually
rethinking its defensive posture you
know the the past couple of decades
actually did Force more Americans to
seriously consider whether or not the
U.S should be the world's policeman a
majority of people say you know what we
should probably be doing Less in terms
of military intervention and military
spending and things like that and it has
the exact opposite on elected officials
um which is deeply disturbing and I
don't quite know how to process that I
mean I remember as part of even the Rand
Paul discussion in 2015 and just general
discussion of military spending back
then it was presumed it was Radical
um of seeming it was presumed that uh we
would have wound down our uh engagements
in both Iraq and Afghanistan and
therefore wouldn't be spending all those
emergency appropriate so you know that
would go down from 150 billion a year or
whatever it was to zero
um and that's not even part of the
discussion at all anymore like I pretty
sure we left Afghanistan I've gotta
maybe check check the notes here let's
get the the Ombudsman play the table we
left it right yeah
the you know that the other thing is
that you also see you know that the the
military is the ultimate jobs program
and not for the people who serve in the
military either but for military
contractors and whatnot and one of the
things that's worth keeping an eye on is
the uh the new uh B-21 bomber uh which
will probably come online which was
announced recently and you know even the
Washington Post as Alan vaderman a long
time reader uh sometimes commenter at uh
reason.com and and similar places notes
that even the Washington Post is saying
what are we doing with this and the
Washington Post had an op-ed on this
saying uh the U.S Air Force has to put
it mildly a mixed record building
strategic bombers over the past 60 years
um and it's true the last two big bomber
programs were a virtually Complete bus
this new one is going to be and by the
time it's operational if it is it'll be
you know redundant or useless because
it's going to be a man bomber and we
have things like the F-35 fighter plane
like this is the hardware that goes into
all of this is kind of an open spigot
for spending for jobs for influence and
then as Catherine was pointing out this
stuff ends up somewhere sometimes it's a
you know a kind of military graveyard in
the middle of Arizona Arizona or Nevada
oftentimes it's somewhere overseas and
occasionally you know we leave it behind
so that it can be turned against us or
our allies sometime in the near future
but it's really worth kind of hammering
home how poor uh how poorly uh
responsive Congress is to things related
to defense and it's also worth
highlighting the continuity of spending
um with the wars in Iraq and Afghanistan
so the New York Times commissioned an
outside group to do an analysis of the
most recent Pentagon budget what they
found was that on info inflation
adjusted terms military spending is set
to reach its highest level since the
peaks in the costs of the Iraq and
Afghanistan Wars between 2008 and 2011
and the second highest in
inflation-adjusted terms since World War
II so we are spending as if we are still
at War and in some ways that tells you
we are effectively in at War
um via you know via proxy
um uh in Ukraine
well our Catherine speaking of Congress
and War
um and uh sort of the abdication of
constitutionally prescribed duties uh
Senator Bernie Sanders the independent
from Vermont who caucuses with the
Democratic party
um he last week or the week before as
the ndaa was winding to its beautiful
858 Billion Dollar close he withdrew
his Yemen War Powers Resolution which
would have stopped some of the ongoing
U.S assistance
um to Saudi Arabia in its prosecution of
the very brutal and deadly uh yemeni uh
Civil War this is a uh something that
was
um uh backed a lot by people in the
libertarian party a lot of anti-war
people on both sides of the aisle and
yet couldn't get enough support
especially from Republicans even though
Republicans had endorsed similar things
uh in the past
um depending on who the president was
and who controlled Congress what does
this tell us about the depressing state
of congressional authorizations and lack
thereof of ongoing War
I mean it sounds like this is a lost
battle uh I don't know I mean I uh
always always always think it's worth
pointing out that we have a very we have
very clear instructions from the
founders about who gets to declare war
and under what conditions and the fact
that we've just chosen to be like um
yeah we're going to ignore those is uh
probably not great
um Bernie Sanders choice to
um to back off of that resolution I
think
is you know it shows that this is still
it's it's all about getting in line with
the party and
um both parties like War
like they just both love it they both
are delighted to do War they're even
more delighted if we can do war and not
have their names on it right it's the
perfect situation they just kind of wave
a hand they give an emergency
authorization they give
um sort of very broad-based open-ended
authority to the president
and then it's both not their problem and
they can kind of take credit if things
go well you know I I appreciate an
anti-war Bernie Sanders that's that's my
favorite Bernie but even even that is
not terribly reliable and we've talked
about this before on this podcast you
know over the years there have usually
been a few folks hanging out somewhere
on the hill that I that you could kind
of count on to at least make a little
fuss about this sort of thing now they
weren't enough but a little fuss a
little of us about congress's
prerogatives and the proper order of
things
um that seems to be fading
I you know I hate to I hate to give up
the fight on both spending and War today
in this podcast but
it's December it's a rough month it's
hard out there for a person
should be constrained is uh you know
Santa works for NORAD right so I mean no
they didn't it all comes together in
December or something I thought I saw a
headline that was like we're not uh were
they threatening to do that because of
budget yeah
they're going to stop tracking Santa
it's terrible firefighters probably
all right we're going to talk even more
about Congress here in a moment
but first friends you might think you've
done everything in your power to ensure
your family in the case of a medical
emergency but what many of us don't
realize is that health insurance won't
always cover the full cost of for
example an emergency medical flight
if you require Air transport even
comprehensive coverage can leave you
with high deductibles and co-pays that's
where air Med Care Network comes in when
you sign up to become a member of The
airmed Care Network should any such
emergency arise you will not see a bill
for air Medical Transport when flown by
a provider airmed care transports more
than 100 000 patients each and every
year that's about a dozen just in the
duration of this podcast and this peace
of mind for you and your whole family
can be yours beginning at the low low
price of just 85 a year listeners to the
Roundtable can get gift cards to their
new memberships for up to fifty dollars
through either Visa or Amazon simply
visit
airmedcarnetwork.com reason and use the
offer code of reason and start
protecting your family do it today
you'll be glad you did all right let's
go back to our discussion of congress's
annual do your job week and talk about
other areas uh legislative areas
that are not unnecessarily being covered
in the cromnibus or the ndaa
um that either are being discussed
because Congress is working this week
and last week or is shamefully not being
a dress and though it should be Peter
why don't you lead us off
so Medicare
has a trust fund it does it has several
trust funds and it has a big one get out
that pays a lot of bills to a lot of
providers for people on Medicare
and it's going to be insolvent in 2028.
and guess what no one is talking about
that
that's it that's what I got for you what
what would they do uh like in a Peter
World
um I mean this is is this a huge
overhaul is there a is there a doc fix I
missed the doc fix so in my world what
they would do is probably something that
looks a lot like the early Paul Ryan
plans which basically say that people
who are within 10 years of being
eligible for Medicare no changes to your
benefits because you've lived a life in
which we've told you that we're that
Medicare will be there for you and so we
are going to uh we're going to keep that
promise for people who are basically 55
and older and I think that that's maybe
not ideal from a Libertarian perspective
but like not a not a completely crazy uh
you know political compromise and then
for people who are younger we're gonna
change the way that this is funded so
that it's sustainable over time
um and so that it's it's a somewhat more
market-based program and so that it is
not you know sort of unlimited uh
benefit you know kind kind of unlimited
payment system right where doctors can
just bill for whatever and there's sort
of no cap on on how much it how much
it's paid and where there's maybe some
relationship between money that people
choose to put into the system and what
they get out of it which is not the case
currently Catherine what is an area that
is either being uh dealt with by Capitol
Hill but kind of on the on the down low
because everything else is going on the
same week or is not being covered and
should be and shame on them
immigration we still have a really
serious problem at our border we have
not resolved the backups the confusion
um the general Mass created by pandemic
era immigration policy I was reminded by
a post on Twitter recently that we also
still have a vaccine mandate for people
entering the country even from Nations
where vaccines remain scarce
um especially perhaps from those
countries you might even say once again
uh there was kind of some talk that
maybe there was a bipartisan immigration
deal that was going to come together
excitingly in this the week that
Congress does its job but no uh the last
headlines that I saw contained phrases
like Dead on Arrival which tragically is
also true of some of the people trying
to get into this country I think that
there is a I really wish we could fix
that there's an eternal
um kind of
uh a lingering mistake or or a a attack
attachment to comprehensive immigration
reform which is not to say that we don't
need comprehensive immigration reform
it's just that that was a term used to
describe negotiations that have stopped
being a viable thing for the most part
uh 15 years ago
um uh because it's kind of too big of a
question to get people to agree uh every
time it's going to involve lots of wall
building
um lots of of tracking of of individuals
um you know of ID programs real ID
programs uh and uh at the same time uh
you know making uh people who are here
on illegally uh legal all of these
there's many of them are contentious
issues and because people can't agree on
them they just don't have a plan in
place for when a political party takes
power in Washington which is the first
two years of every presidency and it
goes away so there isn't any like here's
what we should do to maybe just add the
add a number of visas that would that
would be helpful right well there's also
this there was just this idea that has
haunted our politics for a long time
that the Republicans want you know
border control and the Democrats want to
let in more people and so we could do
those two things at once together they
are not in theory in conflict and if we
did them both together so everyone would
get something they want and then we
could do it that's wrong that didn't
work it turned out that that is not a
viable bargain and yet for some reason
we keep trying to do that bargain
um you know this last uh theoretically
bipartisan deal was a uh a Kirsten
Cinema Jam so I'm sure it wasn't helpful
that she decided to sell her high heel
shoes on the internet and change her
partisan affiliation this week also but
um but yeah this like the the imagined
structure of a bipartisan Bill simply
isn't one that actually Garners
bipartisan support and it's bizarre to
me that Washington can't move on from
that delusion it's also I mean it's
worth pointing out you know this the the
recent deadlock goes back to the late
80s when Reagan signed off on the last
comprehensive immigration reform package
and the Republican narrative coming out
of this was that uh he you know granted
amnesty to uh you know
a million plus illegals living in the
country and didn't do the border
security that we needed and it is
squarely on the Republicans shoulders
right now they are so uh completely
against any acknowledgment that people
come to the country uh you know legally
or illegally and increasing that I mean
it's really significant uh to such a
degree that when George W bush after
winning election in 2004 had talked
about comprehensive immigration reform
along with Social Security privatization
as one of the two priorities that he was
going to go after and even people like
John McCain ended up kind of submarining
all of that somebody who says Pro uh
immigration or republican as you could
see who was in the house or Senate um
that's really the problem and Matt I
think you're right that the only way
forward on any of this stuff is through
very small peaceful piecemeal uh reforms
but you even saw with the dreamers and
whatnot under Obama that Republicans for
reasons that are bizarre because even a
majority a clear majority of Republicans
think that immigration and immigrants
are good for the country that no
Republican uh politician of any
significance will say you know what we
should be letting more people into the
country legally they just cannot
um concede that and that is a big
problem and then you have the
fecklessness of Democrats who just won't
get on with the smaller legal reforms
the key moments uh in all that period
was the
um almost failed uh presidential uh
nominating uh campaign of John McCain
he'd been a co-sponsor along with uh
Teddy Kennedy of of the negotiations to
get bipartisan comprehensive immigration
reform and his campaign almost was was
still born at Birth right Catherine
um uh because of it and like the only
way that he could uh rebound was to
disassociate uh himself from that get
himself off of the negotiations hand
that off to uh his colleague in Arizona
and eventually vote against things that
he had previously sponsored or at least
argue against things that he had
previously sponsored because the Insight
was you couldn't run uh for the
presidents in the Republican party
without uh suddenly talk about talking
about like we need to build the dang
fence as he uh he memorably said in the
Senate campaign ad when he was feeling a
little bit of heat in a in a primary a
few years later and from that point on
um the hawk immigration the hawkish most
hawkish person has either won or
um or competed way above you would have
expected them to in every Republican
primary
and the key was uh and you know this
will last long after Donald Trump
Waddles out of our Lives
um uh you know when Trump came in and
compared illegal immigrants or
immigrants from Mexico to rapists and
not sending their best and the reaction
was his poll numbers shot up
um every single Republican everyone
there wasn't an exception to this we
were running for president at the time
suddenly lost their mind on uh
immigration like Ben Carson was like we
need to close the border of the Atlantic
Ocean
people were talking about how we need to
get like FedEx it's a stamp you know we
can track FedEx packages why can't we
track the the humans come on man
um it was nuts and uh and that the
nuttiness that those lessons have been
learned
um and until
um you know that fever breaks uh but
it's gonna not break for a long time
Nick would go
if I may if I may just to extend the the
discussion about immigration a little
bit you know one of the last good
working kind of mytho poetic definitions
of America was that we were a nation of
immigrants uh you know and this became
the Mantra after World War II which had
to be fair you know had effectively cut
off immigration for most parts of the
country uh most parts of the world for a
while and it started trickling back in
from Mexico uh first and then uh after
the 1964 reforms from Asia in particular
but
you know that rubric that America was a
nation of immigrants John F Kennedy
ghost wrote and possibly ghost read a
book called a nation of immigrants in
the late 50s as he was preparing for uh
presidential uh nominating run and
whatnot but that was a capacious way of
talking about what America was for you
know it was a place where everybody from
all over the world could come and kind
of become themselves and have a second
chance or a first chance and it also was
being adapted in the early 60s to
include black migrants moving from the
south to other parts of the country but
like you know the immigration the role
of immigration and of people coming here
and becoming something that they
couldn't be in their home country or in
their home towns is a really powerful
way of making people kind of get along
while recognizing and even celebrating
difference and I think you know that
that's gone away it partly went away
after the end of the Cold War and also
as immigration started ramping up again
particularly in the 80s and 90s but I
think you know that's a successor
narrative
um you know that we we might want to
revisit because it it comports with the
world the world is only going to become
more and more globalized people are only
going to be moving around more and
mixing more and it's it's really a shame
that the political rhetoric around
immigration is so toxic because it
actually it was a myth about America
that worked really well to include a lot
of people and generate good feelings so
uh Nick what is what is your one thing
that Congress is either doing on quietly
this week or should be doing and is not
this week yeah I mean I guess it's that
they're not but um you know I'm just
going back and I was looking at some uh
stuff uh both Peter at uh reason.com or
raise a magazine and our colleague Emma
Camp have written again about the new or
the new challenges to Biden's student
loan forgiveness uh program and you know
that's going to become a compelling or
you know a you know it's in the courts
and things like that and
um I just wanted to call attention to
the fact that you know the the warrant
for this uh action by the by the Biden
Administration was the heroes Act of
2003 law giving the Secretary of
Education the power to get federal
student relief in connection with the
war or other military operation or
national emergency and you know when you
are forgiving student loan debt to
people who come from households making
up to 250 Grand under the idea that
there's a war or other military
operation or National Emergency going on
something is so wrong and I would love
to see Congress you know actually do
something to knock this down you know to
take it out of the courts uh hopefully
the courts will see fit to keep knocking
this down because it's just it's bad
policy on every possible level uh but
it's also like the the argumentation in
behind it it's like it's it's just awful
and terrible and we shouldn't even
bother having a uh you know a government
of laws if we are going to torture plain
language into whatever is necessary in
order to do whatever we're going to do I
would just rather live under a naked
despot like we are increasingly doing my
nominee for the thing that actually uh
got passed I forget which one it's
through the ndaa uh must be the NDA
because it actually passed um is uh the
Iran hostages Congressional gold medal
act you'll be relieved to know uh has uh
has has passed honoring its resolution
uh honoring
um The Forgotten 52 Americans who were
uh uh who were held hostage I've nothing
wrong with that at all uh just I found
out about it last night because I uh
happened to be following the
conversation with uh yeah like uh 12th
ranked or or ninth rank uh the 2020
presidential candidate Brock Pierce
who's like a crypto bro
um and he uh has a a Super PAC that's
that's doing
um a non-partisan things and this is one
of the things they're doing to to prove
that we can do things and I was like
dude
pretty sure you're born after 1979 Nick
and I remember 1979 but you can't and
indeed he was born in 1980 but
um you know uh gold gold medal uh for
families and those people suffered and
we should remember them so whatever I
would have expected him to have wanted
to be either an nft or a Bitcoin metal I
mean why would Brock Pierce of all
people be uh going back to Mere gold he
can do a lot of different things the
guys involved with Toys for Tots too
Nick he's doing a lot
um and like I'm just saying you're
either a Bitcoin maximalist or you're uh
you know you're kind of a Fiat boy I
don't know
um speaking of Fiat boys let's go to our
end of podcasts this that doesn't work
uh and if podcast what do you call it a
Fiat boy
consuming uh Peter you're a Fiat boy uh
what have you been wait is that what F
boy means yeah it is actually yeah it's
but it's a new F boy is an Italian Fiat
or a polsky Fiat that's the question
what have you been consuming uh so I
watched Avatar the way of water and guys
it ruled it just ruled it's great it's a
genuinely novel and astounding cinematic
experience the use of 3D and high frame
rate photography is incredibly immersive
uh so this is director James Cameron's
first movie in over a decade since the
uh his last one was the first avatar in
2009 and he's created a
computer-generated alien world that just
feels more real than almost anything
else I have ever seen on a movie screen
at times it's like watching a
particularly epic episode of one of
those super Lush Immaculate Nature
Documentaries you know like planet Earth
or blue planet except it's set on a 50
fictional alien planet with peacenik
battle whales they like attack the the
bad Harpoon guys and it's just it's just
awesome at every moment and yes yes you
could argue that the story is kind of
cheesy at times Cameron absolutely
indulges in a bunch of very silly
eco-spiritualism that is not
particularly to my taste But ultimately
it's he's telling the story that he's
been telling for 35 years now going back
to the first Terminator and Aliens
um and and True Lies and even Terminator
2 which are all kind of found family
films about struggling families that are
sort of you know that that maybe are not
actually biological families but are
like going through hard times and figure
out how to come together to kick ass and
win and be awesome and the experience of
it is just it's just a Wonder it's the
kind of grand scale uh forward-looking
ambitious filmmaking that I think has
gone out of fashion in the age of
endless Marvel sequels which 10 to use
credit computer generated effects as a
crutch James Cameron is a Visionary and
he is trying to take movie making into
the future trying to capitalize on the
promise of technology to make movie
Magic and to make entertainment that is
more astounding and more spectacular and
I think Avatar the way of water is
largely successful in that it is it is
truly a spectacle of the kind I have
never seen before
wow Catherine what have you been
consuming well Peter's recommendation is
the most on brand for him you can
imagine I'm gonna go the other way and
say
um I watched Argentina defeat France in
the World Cup wow guys what I know I
know I'm as surprised if you are I know
it's football I understand
um it was pretty great I understand that
this is potentially one of the greatest
sporting events of all time and so I'm
glad that I decided to watch it to be
clear I decided to watch it because I
heard there were going to be snacks
um so I went for the snacks for the for
the football players or for you for me
this next for me at my friend's house
um and I did eat some super delicious
um Argentinian snacks which made me
happy then that the good guys won
um I uh particularly enjoyed the part
where
um adult men wept the world over
I just I just like men to have feelings
sometimes and if this is what it takes
then I'm all for it I had them about the
CG whales yeah so like say everybody can
get their feelings whatever way they
want um I will say I presciently hated
the first avatar like walked out and
said this is bad and here's all the
reasons why
um but also it made me really motion
sick and so I'm scared to go see this
one but um the World Cup was great and I
know that that is not a particularly
novel recommendation but
um maybe the only form of nationalism
that only makes me a teeny bit
uncomfortable but mostly happy
it was uh it was awesome except for the
wrong team one but uh yes that was good
Nick um you're crying even right now uh
what did you consume
oh yeah no I'm crying all over the place
man uh and uh the my recommendation uh
is Another World building uh experiment
as well but it's by historian Beverly
Gage who has written G-Man Jagger Hoover
in the making of the American Century uh
it's a phenomenal Recreation of Jagger
Hoover's life and times and um it raises
a really fascinating question uh which I
will be putting to uh Beverly Gage uh in
a for in a future episode of the recent
interview podcast which is does a
national police force inevitably become
corrupted and used for crass political
or personal
um excesses but uh G-Man Jagger Hoover
in the making of the American Century is
um a phenomenal
um kind of uh addendum to uh Tim
Weiner's enemies a history of the FBI
that came out maybe a decade ago or so
really fascinating and particularly in a
moment now where you know our our big
moments where we're like oh my you know
we need to root out terrorists we need
to be worried about the word this and
that Etc has passed kind of going back
and looking at Jager Hoover the long
time you know 48-year head of the
Federal Bureau of Investigation and the
way in which his power kind of
incrementally increased and kind of
corrupted him as well as he corrupted
the institution is well worth uh you
know kind of puzzling over while we have
kind of a breather in terms of National
Security State issues my recommendation
which I'm still reading through but I'm
in taking a very heavy nutrient value
from is uh 1948 the history of the first
arab-israeli war by Benny Morris uh
Israeli historian came out in 2008 I
believe it was of for those who are
ignorant about Middle East conflicts
which I definitely am
um it's a very very good and dense
primer primer uh any way you want to
pronounce it it's that and very detailed
about the run-up to the creation of the
state of Israel and all the wars and the
British mandate and uh all that business
been going on a Jag in that direction
for a while and just really well done I
appreciated it uh it's rare to read a
history where
um it uh you know there's a way in for
people who know everything about it and
the way and for people like me again who
are ignorant
um and uh and it can be read in both
ways and uh and certainly provides uh
context that uh
enriches uh the discussion of what's
happening right now in Israel which is
new government some bad people
um it's it's look looking pretty uh uh
dicey uh and they're I think we're
running up towards a possible pretty
significant split between
um uh Jews in America and Jews in Israel
about what's happening there
um and that's will eventually or sooner
rather than later affect foreign policy
in the state of a lot of people living
in the West Bank and whatnot but anyways
a great book 1948 Betty Morris check it
out uh all right thanks for checking us
out this week
um like our podcasts uh listen to more
of reason.com podcast Nick what do you
got teed up coming in the great state of
the city of New York uh we've got on
January 4th a reason Speak Easy
featuring uh drug policy experts and
harm reduction reformers Andrea tatarski
of the Center for Optimal living and Joe
journalist and author Maya solovitz go
to reason.com
events to get details and tickets
uh all right uh we will catch you on the
other side of Christmas so Merry
Christmas to everybody
um and uh the other side of Christmas
sounds like a very good uh Hallmark
movie
uh you know with a little maybe it's a
terrible disaster uh yeah cannibalism a
plane crash on Christmas Eve and uh
honestly I think you could just do it as
a straight Hallmark movie like uh big
city gal goes back to her hometown to
find love on the other side of Christmas
I'm picturing a dark Clive barkaresque
fantasy in which on Christmas someone
looks into their mirror and they see the
Christmas tree it's behind them and they
go into the mirror and then suddenly
they're on the other side
there are pink lasers in this aren't
there oh yeah
[Music]